Friday the 7th of April
we were traveling up to the North of
Israel to spend the week of pesach with
my parents and my sister and nephews on
the Sea of Galilee in tiberias and my
parents set up in a separate car with my
sister and nephews and my wife and I
have two cars and she was in the car
with Maya and Rina I was in a car with
Tally and Yehuda and Karen was dropped
off in Jerusalem because she was working
at a an orphanage where she works during
the year and she had to be there for
Shabbat
as we got to the North of Israel
we received a call from my sister who
was way behind who said that they'd been
a terrorist attack on the route
and we'll be okay so I said we were fine
I said I'll just check Lucy but I'm sure
she's fine I called Lucy no answer I
called Maya no answer I called real no
answer I noticed that there was missed
call from Maya at 10 52
and this was about 11 30.
um then you know we were slightly
panicking at this point
um and I looked on Google family link
and I found that they were at the hammer
Junction and that seemed to be where
this big girl was this attack was
um
and my son I think received on a website
uh for attacks in Israel because
unfortunately there is such a site a
photograph of the car just the car and
we spotted our suitcases in it covered
in blood
so you can imagine this Panic
um don't know what to do turn around
drive straight to the camera down
Junction like a lunatic we get there at
about maybe 12 o'clock
um we see the car we're too far away to
see the car they won't let me get near
to it they tell me it's not good to sit
anyway
and um anyway long story short we waited
for half an hour and I said look I have
to go to the hospital because I hear
that Lucy's been taken to the hospital
they wouldn't confirm it with Lucy
um I need some ID before I can actually
go because you know please God it's not
them
um eventually they gave me a buyer's ID
card and then we we knew the worst
um so we bombed down the motorway back
to Jerusalem we came to the hospital
she'd just been taken into uh intensive
care and she's been prepared for um for
the operation and we accomplished it
down to the operation we waited there
and the events unfolded like that so I
lost my two beautiful daughters and my
beautiful wife in that attack We buried
them the girls were buried on Sunday
um Lucy there was some hope she was on a
life support machine so she fought for
her life she bought her up for her life
it turned out that she was able to give
life to five other people through
transplants so we agreed to do that
and she was buried on the Tuesday I've
sort of lost track of time
and now we're here to tell me a bit
about her and your daughters as well of
course
um Lucy was an exceptional uh human
being
yes she was a community Builder she was
someone who gave
um and I think that was really her
defining feature and because she gave
she encouraged other people to give and
I'm feeling this now that people that
she gave to because not so much my
personality are coming and just giving
everything and uh it's it's incredible I
think the kids picked up from that and
and they've learned to give so um it's
uh you know Maya
was giving a year of volunteering in the
south of Israel in a development town in
a school and she was working as a as a
counselor to kids in ninth grade and the
amount of things that I've heard about
that is you know incredible the
individual stories about the impact she
had with individuals
and Rina was just a tremendous Giver she
was took responsibility for things that
were really not her responsibility and
if she decided to do something she would
carry it through to the end and people
would trust her she was at boarding
school so she would stay up all night
chatting to girls particularly girls who
were struggling in in the group and she
would try and help them through their
difficulties and she often would go to
sleep till three four in the morning and
then she get up at seven so usually by
the time she came back to us she was a
wreck and we wouldn't see much of her
until sort of 24 hours of sleep and then
we'd get a few hours and that should be
off really as a counselor in a frat with
a youth group where she was looking
after a group of 20 girls who were 12
year old girls
and she was just busy busy busy the
whole time you must be very proud of him
extremely proud of all of them your wife
literally gave life she has saved the
lives of five other people through
giving her some of her organs in her
death to be donated to them I mean
that's remarkably selfless we're very
proud that you know she saved five lives
to to a corneas as well so that's uh
another two operations will take place
um and one of them was an Arab and I
think that is significant to us because
Lucy was very much into uh you know
peaceful relations with our neighbors
and um I think she would have been very
proud that she saved a life of an Arab
even in this situation the man or men
who killed your wife and daughters has
not been caught yet what are your
feelings towards him I have told people
I don't hold any hate towards them I
feel that the Israeli Security Forces
will do what they usually do which is
track them down and bring them to
justice which I think is right because
it prevents the next attack that they
might might do and I pray for the safety
of the Israeli soldiers who go in and
risk their lives in order to protect the
Jewish people effectively and Arab
citizens because a lot of these attacks
don't discriminate between Jews and
Arabs they couldn't necessarily known
that this was a Jewish car maybe they
saw her head head covering but there are
two million Israeli Arabs who drive in
cars with yellow number plates as you
know living here and had it been one of
them three beautiful Arab girls would
have been killed mercilessly by these
terrorists that's unfortunately what
happened sometimes in this country as
well you lived in Israel I think since
2005. you met you lived in UK for many
years you're born there you met Lucy
there when you were both at University
what does Britain mean to you I love
Britain we love Britain we came to
Israel because as you can see the warm
hug that we've had in this situation I
think is just unique I mean we've had
the whole Israeli people coming and
around us in a way that the British
Community is very close but it's not as
as close as this I mean when a disaster
happens in Israel we're all brothers and
sisters and you really feel it now as
people are bringing food and they're
bringing everything and it's really just
it's like being part of a massive family
so it's
unbelievable unfortunately when you're
in this situation which nobody else
should ever have to bear you receive a
lot of emails and what's that and in the
middle of the night it was a bit of a
comfort I couldn't sleep so I was
opening some of the emails and you know
one of them just spoke to me it was from
Alex Balfour from Belfort Capital group
in London and it started as follows as
you can probably tell from my name
um I have a close connection to Israel
and to therefore what you're going
through so clearly his ancestor was the
author of the Balfour Declaration so I
just responded to him Alex you should be
proud of your ancestor because he stood
up at the time and he issued the buffer
declaration which basically gave the
British uh statement of the that they
would create a Jewish state in mandated
Palestine I think James cleverley has
shown that he is of the level of Belfair
and I want to call his revised letter
the cleverly Declaration he states there
can be no justification for such
senseless and abhorrent violence and I
unequivocally condemned this act of
terrorism the UK remains steadfast in
our commitment to work with the Israeli
authorities and all parties in the
region to bring an end to the terrorism
that Israel faces and to the cycle of
violence which as we've seen all too
clearly is so destructive
and I feel that that statement saying
that Britain stands unequivocally
against Violence Against Terror is a
landmark in British history and terms of
its way it's dealt with the state of
Israel because up until now there's not
been unequivocal uh condemnation of
violence there's actually been a very
sort of wishy-washy condemnation of
violence which I think is slightly
um the foreign office is uh fault just
find the
when you do go to sleep at night
how do you remember your wife and
daughters I decided to focus on the good
and I suddenly focused on my remaining
daughters and my son Karen tally and
Yehuda and I thought about them and I
felt a sense of calm and I was able to
sleep and my advice to people going
through any type of trauma or any
difficulties in their life is when you
think about the good and there's so much
good in the world
and you don't think about the bad
your life is much better you're much
calmer and you're in a much better
position to cope so that's all I can do
at the moment